investigators want to know why a masked
gunman fired a burst of shots at a
federal courthouse in Dallas federal
officers shot and killed the 22 year old
Army veteran yesterday NCTM national
correspondent Jericka Duncan is outside
Earl Coble Federal Building in downtown
Dallas
Jericka the gunman was killed was anyone
else hurt good morning Tony just one
other person at worker suffered minor
injuries she was taking cover but really
think about this we're talking more than
300 people that were inside this
building
when the gunman opened fire thankfully
federal agents assigned to protect this
place were able to quickly stop the
attacker in his tracks it took just
seconds for federal agents to confront
the gunman who opened fire outside a
busy federal courthouse in Dallas on
Monday but for the actions of the
Federal Protective Service officers this
likely would have been a very deadly
incident officers shot and killed the
shooter identified as Brian Isaac Clyde
Tom Fox a photographer with the Dallas
Morning News was hiding just steps away
from the shooter outside the building
Fox captured this photograph of the
gunman clad in tactical gear holding a
high-powered rifle with more than 150
rounds of ammunition just pray that he
didn't walk past me because I'm in woman
I'm in plain sight and if you saw me
sitting there with a camera he would I
have no doubt he shot me just feet from
the shooting about two hours later as a
precaution
the bomb squad detonated controlled
explosions on a vehicle believed to be
tied to the gunman the FBI is now
reviewing his military history and posts
on social media which featured weapons
Clyde served as an infantryman for 18
months before graduating from college in
May we have more than 200 FBI agents and
partners aggressively pursuing every
lead in this investigation in order to
identify his family members associates
and try to get to the bottom of what
motive was investigators don't believe
the gunman actually entered the
courthouse you can see this yellow
crime-scene tape behind me FBI agents
say they will continue to investigate
this crime scene for the next two or
three days they also did raid Clyde's
apartment in neighboring Fort Worth but
they are not saying what they found at
this time tony sirico i'll take it thank
you